[Applaudissements]
lorsque nous prononçons le mot histoire
d'ailleurs dites-le pour voir
super maintenant je voudrais que vous
pensiez deux secondes
à l'image que vous avez eu en tête quand
vous allez prononcé ce mot
et moi je suis presque sûr qu'il y en a
parmi vous qui ont directement eu
l'image de leur cours de collège ou de
lycée de leur livre qui pesait une tonne
autant dans leur sac que dans leur
mémoire et qui il faut bien le dire
était loin de tous nous parler
et ben c'est absolument pas ce dont il
est question ici
il est question de s'imprégner non pas
de l'histoire mais des histoires car
elles sont une infinité et elles ont
toutes quelque chose à nous offrir
alors si vous le voulez bien durant les
quelques minutes que nous envoie passer
ensemble ce soir j'aimerais vous donner
ne serait-ce qu'une idée de tout ce que
les histoires ont à nous donner
et parce qu'il faut bien commencer
quelque part je voudrais vous parler
d'une des premières histoires qu'on nous
a tous raconté peu importe notre âge la
fable vous vous souvenez des fables du
corbeau et du renard de la Fontaine tout
ça ça vous parle
et bien la fontaine depuis son 17e
siècle a appris aux enfants que nous
étions à se méfier des flatteurs
comprendre la vraie valeur du travail ou
encore se dire qu'on avait toujours
besoin d'un plus petit que soi en somme
il nous a donné des enseignements des
valeurs et des idées utiles pour toute
une vie
et ça il l'a fait en nous racontant des
histoires le voilà le cœur de mon idée
et les sens de ma passion
l'histoire ou les histoires à l'instar
des Fables de La Fontaine ont des
milliers de choses à nous offrir
en premier lieu elle nous offre sur un
plateau d'argent les erreurs du passé
alors oui je sais très bien ce qu'on
peut dire que c'est les erreurs de
grands hommes aux conséquences sont
communes mesure avec celle que nous
pourrions commettre c'est vrai
mais au même titre que vous ne serez
jamais Napoléon Bonaparte guidance qui
lui reste de troupes après sa défaite en
Russie vous ne serez jamais mettre
corbeau tenant son bac un fromage et
pourtant rien ne vous a empêché de
retenir la leçon de Maître Corbeau de
vous mettre à sa place quand vous étiez
petit
ce que je veux vous dire c'est qu'il
faut faire voler en éclats cette
barrière qui oppose hier et aujourd'hui
où les grands hommes des plus modestes
parce que cette barrière elle est
uniquement dans nos esprits alors que
l'histoire elle elle est omniprésente
bah tenez l'omniprésence de l'histoire
on peut en parler
je suis sûr qui en a parmi vous même une
bonne partie qui pour venir ici ce soir
ont réglé leur GPS sur le 14 avenue
Saint-Laurent au 91400 ORSAY
vous vous êtes donc guidés grâce à une
technologie qui n'aurait jamais vu le
jour sans la guerre froide
cette même technologie
identifiant
une rue numérotée selon un système
inventé par Napoléon et qui porte le nom
d'un martyr romain mort en 258
vous voyez tout ce qu'une simple adresse
peut nous apporter comme histoire
religieuse technologique et
administrative de notre pays et même du
monde de manière générale
pour peu qu'on laisse notre notre esprit
ça donnait à sa propre curiosité
et notre curiosité
si on la laisse courir si nous lui
permettons pas de s'essouffler
nous découvrons encore autre chose à
l'histoire
mais cette fois-ci ce n'est pas un
enseignement c'est une vertu un œil
nouveau sur tout ce qui nous entoure
la connaissance de l'histoire
nous permet de voir une deuxième
dimension à ce que nous trouvons beau et
de trouver de la beauté à si on est de
prime abordé pour vous
mais là ça vous parle pas ce que je vous
dis
l'un n'en vous y retrouvez pas donc ce
que je vais faire c'est à mon tour vous
raconter une histoire
une histoire toute bête
d'une visite ou une visite de Orsay avec
ma copine
on se baladait simplement dans l'allée
principale c'est la veille toutes les
sculptures néoclassiques
on regardait justement un peu toutes les
statues
quand soudain mon regard a été comme
happé par l'une d'elles qui me
paraissait vraiment familière
cette statue c'était le David et Goliath
dont on a Mercier celle-là là
et là où mon amoureuse voyez une
sculpture à la beauté indiscutable elle
avait raison
moi je voyais un objet d'émerveillement
parce que je connaissais l'histoire de
David et Goliath vous êtes certains
d'entre vous à mon avis la connaissent
aussi mais je vais faire un rapide
résumé
j'ai donc commencé à lui raconter avec
une joie immense et une pointe d'orgueil
absolument pas dissimulé
que Goliath était un soldat de l'armée
philistine dans l'Ancien Testament aux
proportions gargantuesque qui avait pour
mission
de soumettre les peuples adultes de la
vallée des térébentes
et ce géant
à plat l'armée d'Israël a lui envoyer un
soldat qui serait capable de le vaincre
en combat singulier il réitérera son
appel pendant 40 jours et au bout du 40e
jour David un adolescent fils de berger
un peu frêle répondit à l'appel de
Goliath il se présenta devant lui muni
de sa fronde et lui lança une pierre qui
se loge en plein milieu du front du
géant et la Bâtie d'un coup
et pendant que je racontais ça
je voyais les gens autour de moi
ralentir la cadence de leur repas prêter
une oreille discrète à ce que je
racontais
et même lorsque je finis allait regarder
l'entaille sur le front de Goliath juste
ici
et c'est à ce moment-là que je le
ressenti le plus grand plaisir que
l'histoire puisse nous apporter celui de
raconter
ce plaisir sans lequel je ne serai pas
là devant vous simplement et sans lequel
l'histoire n'existerait juste pas
d'ailleurs
ce plaisir
intense de me dire que ce jour-là les
gens autour de moi ne sont pas non pas
juste regarder une statue on trouvait
jolie puis ils sont mis en regardant une
autre non ils sont ressortis avec un
petit morceau d'histoire
un peu comme s'ils avaient volé un
infime fragment de cette statue
et même peut-être qu'ils sont ressortis
avec une étincelle de curiosité
leur disant de regarder un peu autour
d'eux de comprendre l'histoire autour de
mais là je me fais peut-être des
illusions
mais bon si après ce que je viens de
vous raconter David et Goliath les
Fables de La Fontaine Napoléon tout ça
même si pour vous l'histoire c'est
encore quelque chose d'un peu abstrait
d'un peu emmêlée qui appartient vraiment
définitivement en salle de classe
j'aimerais vous montrer que vous portez
tous une histoire
d'abord votre vie en elle-même est une
histoire ça va de soi
mais elle est avant tout un chapitre
un chapitre de l'histoire de l'humanité
pourquoi pas
un chapitre de l'histoire de France si
on veut
mais elle est avant tout un chapitre de
l'histoire de votre famille
d'ailleurs votre famille du moins votre
nom de famille vous savez d'où il vient
bon si vous vous appelez le maire le
Roux le grand ou chevalier il y a de
bonne chance pour que vous sachiez d'où
vient votre famille et qui était vos
ancêtres
mais si j'ai un peu de chance il y a des
Lefèvre dans cette salle
non dommage mais bref vous connaissez
sûrement au moins tout ça le faire et
quelqu'un ici
ah j'ai quelqu'un super
et ben votre ami là à personne dont j'ai
pas très bien identifié
ne s'est surement pas que son nom vient
du latin Faber qui veut dire fabriquer
qu'il a donné le mot orfèvre et qu'il
désignait au Moyen-Âge un forgeron
est-ce qu'il y a des Martins dans la
salle
oui des Martins vous êtes le nom plus
donné en France je prenais pas
énormément de risques sur celui-là
votre nom vient lui du dieu Mars c'est
une déformation c'est pour ça que
martien était aussi comme Martin donc
vous venez aussi du Dieu de du dieu de
la guerre
là je me fais on parle de nom de famille
ça me rappelle quelqu'un
j'avais un professeur de câblage au
lycée monsieur Malinowski
qui refusait catégoriquement nous
appeler par nos prénoms
parce que selon lui le nom de famille et
l'été le porter en barre de notre
famille qu'il racontait son histoire et
qu'on devait en être fier
monsieur Malinski avait raison
il avait tellement raison qu'il a dit en
une phrase ce qui m'a pris pas loin de
deux semaines à écrire et 10 minutes
avant de vous
mais quand on y pense 10 minutes c'est
si peu c'est rien c'est absolument
insuffisant à qui que ce soit pour
parler de sa passion en fait une passion
ça se raconte tout au long d'une vie au
fil de ce qu'on lit de ce qu'on voit de
ce qu'on apprend des gens que l'on
rencontre parce que oui pour moi
l'histoire et même la passion de manière
générale c'est avant tout des rencontres
des rencontres avec des personnalités
avec d'autres passionnés
qui vous donne un nouveau regard sur
votre passion ou qui même vous en donne
une toute nouvelle
et bien j'espère
que cette soirée
ça a été pour vous une rencontre
une rencontre qui vous a permis
de vouloir ouvrir les yeux qui vous a
donné cette curiosité
qui vous a donné envie de regarder
l'histoire et le beau qu'elle suscite
tout autour de vous
et si la prochaine fois
vous passez dans une rue
Sainte-Geneviève où vous arrêtez à la
station de métro Duroc vous vous dites
mais qui est-ce que c'était
Sainte-Geneviève ou alors mais qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait le maréchal du rock
et vous allez chercher la réponse
alors les quelques minutes que nous
aurons passé ensemble ce soir
auront vraiment été utile et auront
vraiment transmis parce que signifie
pour moi le mot passion
je vous remercie infiniment et je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée
[Applaudissements]